und ich hab noch in anderen nachteilig
ränder gerade rücken ich habe kein
schwert und antwort der hermann
spitzhacke wie wir das besser als mein
stein schwer
hallo ich ihn freuen und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren runde
survival games allerdings heute auf dem
golm hd.de k server alle drauf komme
genau womit komme weil genau ihr ding
komme habe ich auch mit ihm im
schlepptau und wir spielen eine super
end to end steine sind und alles und der
gommel der ist natürlich admin das heißt
er kann es das spiel sofort starten da
hier offen kommando hier kommt spart
aber das auch richtig gut weil hier
haben wir einen namens change platten
und hier ist eine kiste noten blöcke
noten blog ist seine kiste damit man
nicht hier von den ganzen links typen
echt was für ein schwert gold wert man
kann doch nicht schlagen ich werde in
die mitte rennen dann auch noch ein paar
noten blöcke ja warum haben wir nur
noten blog hier drauf damit man ein
scharnier wird besser gegen hacker
geschützt ist wie halt auf diversen
anderen server ist einfach momentan eher
modern möchte ich mal mein und ich habe
hier kontra vorgeschlagen
viele menschen im change plugin dass wir
hier eine runde aufnehmen weil er sicher
beschwert hat dass er immer getötet wird
auf der haid und nauru mit schwert das
kann ja nur eine gute runde werden
ich kann ja auch aber die verwundbarkeit
ist endlich kann ja auch ein schwert
geben aber ich würde sagen wir machen
eigentlich kein team erstmal okay mit
sie eigentlich immer auf youtube und ihr
wollt ja ihr habt euch auch mal
gewünscht dass das ganze ein bisschen
gegeneinander abläuft als wären wir auch
ganz normal verfeindet hier einfach die
sache ist auch die ich habe mein name
auch geändert und ich glaube du weißt
gar nicht wie ich heiße oder ich weiß
auch nicht geheilt aber du weißt ich
halte aber schauen wir machen auf jeden
fall kein team ok hab ne kiste so schön
oh ich hab ne steinachs sehr schön ich
habe einstein schwer
nein ein stein schwer deutschland schwer
aber ich habe keine restaurant ist das
problem
okay und ich hab noch in anderen
nachteilig ländergruppe tor ich habe
kein schwert und alternative torwand
spitzhacke wie wir das besser als mein
stein schwer machten diamant spitzhacke
wirklich mehr schaden als stein schwert
verdammen
ich bin einfach weiter ich versuche
einfach woanders hinzugehen also das ist
ja ein ganz gut gelöst das natürlich
alles auf deutsch
klar dass ein mit sicherheit aus dem
video unser achter bisher hey ich bin
hier genau so einfach mal raus holt mit
silber männern übrigens nicht auf aber
durch die trotzdem in der beschreibung
gekommen macht super geile videos aber
dann muss ich auch mal erwähnen obwohl
dass er seine abonnenten wahrscheinlich
eh wissen warum schauen sie wenn ja
gerade weil wir einfach geil sind
ich bin eine kiste ja die sind gerade
alle im spielen ja leider aber hier
haben wir eine zwei von 24 spielern 14
auf das leise dann immer deathmatch oder
was heißt das dann mal das bedeutet es
ist einfach das dann nur noch 2000 dann
sind noch zwei da aber man hat wenn du
auch viele leute leben hier den vorteil
man bekommt ein kompass und der kompass
derzeit in richtung vom nächsten spieler
und wenn man eigentlich dabei 25 minuten
spielt wird man auch in das finale
gepostet
wie oft er halt also da muss irgendwie
diesmal nicht erwarten bis vier spieler
tod noch leben da wartet einfach ok 25
minuten sind gerade um dann kommt ein
countdown im chat dann wird man in die
mitte gepaart mit allen anderen spielern
und hat halt da auch so ein finale sag
ich mal
aber so ein direct ist das bei vier
spielern so eine grenze ist das haben
wir nicht dort kriegt man ohne kompass
aber der hat blitze und so was alles
sind die da er blitzende ich nie gestört
aber ich hier wichtiger server geht doch
nicht drauf das ist nur für die über
profis sage ich mal auf jeden fall so
für dich ich würde sagen ich mache ganz
kurzen kleinen cut und dann sehen wir
sofort wieder in der nächsten runde die
anhänge weil ich also für okay weil er
das dauert hier noch moment glaube ich
kleinkind noch einfach zweitligisten
menschen wie kann ich nicht ganz ehrlich
nicht nein weil die server ja alle auf
externen ruth sind also ich kann da gar
nicht gerade darauf zugreifen
das plugin wurde komplett selber getötet
und damit das komplette haben wir hier
drei server hierfür und die survival
gamestar in sind halt alle auf einem
extra als auch von externen und da kann
ich kann nicht drauf aber wir haben hier
zwei zwei situationen damen kann das
sind 2 sg täglich hier wir warten
einfach mal eine minute ich gebe dem
ganzen noch eine minute dann ist denke
ich meine erweitere arena frei und auch
hier die wir die and web dies auch bald
wir vorbei ist so schön klein ist und
eine wichtige sache noch für dich wir
haben pro kiel bekommst du hier noch
zehn survival prinz oder ja genauso wie
points das sind die level punkte
damit kann man nicht eingehen schwert
verzaubern das ist einfach wie kam aber
mac bei mcdonald's jemanden tötet des
kriegs 14 also steht bei dem level 2
sowie bei mcdonald's quasi wenn man den
tötet kriegt man einfach zehn von diesen
punkten und dann kann man die equipe
burger einlösen oder ganz genau so ist
dass man wird dabei bedienen von conny
und konya sekunden kommt uns auch
irgendwann eine warteschleife ein rein
aber ich glaube dass müssen oder das
geht hier oft leider noch nicht ach so
und jetzt diesen werden nur die
angezeigt die also bei tab die gerade
hier stehen das sind die die entweder
premium gekauft haben
moderator sind youtube wie ip in lila
oder einatmen und die anderen sind alle
unsere bahn dann haben wir uns sichtbar
gemacht damit dass sie in der lobby die
nehme ich natürlich natürlich etwas mehr
legt er war halt ein rhythmus haben wir
einfach hier die masse unsichtbar
gemacht damit das nicht so auffällt
das macht ihr eigentlich der half
genauso und damit derzeit nicht so voll
gesperrt wird haben wir den auch
komplett ausgeblendet
das heißt es gut du kannst ja auch nix
schreibe ich könnte nur hier mit safe
schreiben moment luca das könnte ich
erkannte dass auch habe ich das
geschrieben hast du test geschrieben
nein schadewaldt server nach ich dachte
ich habe geschrieben
entweder spielen wir könnten wir arena 1
spielen oder wir warten noch einen
moment warten noch mal auf die and
mapping sprinterin 1 ok
die dauert aber bestimmt länger diese
taschen voller egal ob ihr ein und dann
wieder / damit sie ja okay ich habe
einen namen so habe ich auch einen arena
einfach starten schon
ich weiß ja ich weiß welchen nahm ich
habe aber ich verrate nicht okay ich
startete die arena ok ich mal einfach
dann wieder so ankündigung macht das
dann aber auch gerade an
sommer starten so und da sind wir wieder
zurück bei wie survival games zusammen
mit dem hd hier in survival games 1 erst
jetzt einen kleinen kap miterlebt und
die arena startet auch gleich sofort ich
habe mich wieder umbenannt ich werde ihn
nicht sagen wie ich heiße weil wir
obwohl doch lass mal gehen lassen wir
miteinander so dass sie das ein scheiß
jetzt hier
wie heißt du ich bin eng wie der tasten
typen wie ich habe ich habe nur noch
gelesen ich habe entweder truhe von
meinem namen oder taste irgendwas von
beiden ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz
sicher was also tut mir leid das weiß
ich nicht was bist du wer bist du denn
ich bin cowen user fünf wieder
schon wieder warte mal finde ich dich
irgendwo muss doch stehen irgendwo hier
noch nicht fest der borussen der der der
der countdown ada 9
so komme hier stehe gerechnet er kann
sein dass das kleine sekunden sind
eigentlich schon aber gerade das ist
halt die sache vorhin die user die m
unsichtbar wahl und dich halt nur
gesehen haben aber du die nicht
versuchen auch kann ich alle
reinzuschauen
genau das gleiche problem wie damals
trouble main will auf der heißen auch
duale eingezäunt und haben euch
natürlich verfolgt wie wales
und gerade weil wir da auch so lange
gewartet haben uns alle natürlich
entdeckt haben wollen die ich auch alle
in die arena ein und ist so weit dass
wir gestartet ist
sieben sekunden gelingt übrigens auch
davor ja ich bin ja ich bin genau
gegenüber eigentlich genau gegenüber
genau gegenüber ja ist also schuld sie
rechts ja ich habe meinen ob tief fallen
gerade nicht drin weil es auch in das
ist natürlich dann nicht ganz so gut
denn sechs sekunden also 10 60 sekunden
noch mal was da los ist
ihr seht schon deshalb nicht total
scheiße also geht am besten nicht drauf
also ich kann ja auch überhaupt nicht
weiterempfehlen also allein schon die
ipod touch eines ip
navigon hat ich bitte dich 5 was ist das
sind da könnte man auch direkt in die m4
hier wo sind kommen gute herr reimann
wenn ich jetzt was den chat schreibe mir
nicht an tim gelling oder ich weiß es
nicht ich habe keine ahnung und ein
computer so drei sekunden noch achtung
nein warte auf die 2 man muss hier ist
keine kiste bei mir drunter um ist da
nicht ja ich habe einen bogen und pfeile
schön links ja wie schlagen sich schon
laufe ich kenne die karte kaum wo bist
du bist du bist genau da dir genau ganz
gehindert ihr hier hier hier hinter dir
ja komm komm komm ok oft hinterher ich
hab den bogen im notfall schieße ich
einfach alle gegner ab die dich noch da
und ich hab eine schaufel uns verfolgt
unter den hier töten
lieber nicht oder ok auf medien weiter
müssen wir auch männer braucht eine
ladung irgendwo noch eine truhe ich also
noten block im kreis auch sehr gut sind
einfach zu mehr durch gelaufen da wo du
bist immer noch so gut da ist eine insel
doch wahrscheinlich kisten bestimmt aber
obwohl ich glaube aufdeckt ruhe weil auf
der truhe auf der insel gab es nur eine
truhe ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher aber
wenig sein
ich finde da was ich darüber
ich auch hier bin ich hier hallo tasten
prügler 670 ordner könnten die man
verfolgt uns das ist ein wirklicher
vorteil
ja das ist wirklich cool denn wenn man
dann elegant mit einbinden könnte dass
man dann so eigenes kind oder so dass
wir auch kinder hast du hab ich ja oh ja
das ist cool hier ist die kiste
ich hab ne steine holz axt ok schade das
ist ja jetzt auch noch ein schwein auf
den baum um einen türken gut ich habe
einen bogen nicht eingerollt sagst ich
verwechsle summer und daraufhin
besonders dahin ist und tun genau darauf
jetzt mal hin
ok ich komme mal wieder mit ich meine du
kennst die karte bestimmt schon tausend
mal besser als ich mit welcher karte
bislang kein gestiegen sei wie games mit
der ost wird eine erste wird er hier
also eigentlich das war nicht meine
erste das war meine erste wasser weil
wir games zwei die kenne ich eigentlich
relativ gut auswendig meisten auswendig
kenne ich mittlerweile survival games
vier weil ich dir halt unendlich lange
mit um gespielt gespielt habe mit und
gespielt gespielt habt ihr doch solches
auge auf die insel okay ich gebe gerne
hierhin immer aufteilen
geteilte arbeit das macht doch gleich
doppelt so viel spaß und gamestop
schwimmen
der schwimmkurs ist der insel drauf ist
oder wenn ich hier angekommen und noch
richtig sehr kohle aber nicht abbauen
aber als turm drauf also am besten erst
wenn du einfach dar auf der insel bleibt
sich treu mir kurz die sachen wenn er
denn welche drin sind und dann gehen wir
irgendwie wieder eine mit oder für ein
paar leute okay weil ich hab erst
gelangen weil ich gerade dem zentrum
dackeln ich habe irgendwie das gefühl
ich finde hier gar keine noten blog ja
ich habe keine ahnung leider stimmt
noten blöcken immer die augen aufhalten
hier ist eigentlich gar nix auf der
insel auch schade aber auch war
natürlich klar dass ich genau die insel
dann auch nehme einmal 0 drauf ist ich
laufe um die insel herum und
realisierung laufen kann weil da so eine
komische glas konnte wiederum
beim staffellauf der vor der seite rauf
genau da wo du gerade bist genau da auf
den steinblock springen
das ja locker hier der jump'n'run profi
aus apps und ich kann sehr helfen
hier kann ich ausstellung wird denn den
dings jetzt bitte seine kids at ist ein
kitz und da ist ein schwert und fünf
erfahrungs fläschchen was für ein
schwert ein holzschwert ok geil ich habe
ein bogen durch ein holzschwert perfekt
ja da geht es ja nicht nur hatten wir ja
heute auch noch nicht überhaupt weil in
der endrunde
du bist du eigentlich sollte schon
gerade in richtung thomas auf der
komplett entgegengesetzten seite also
ich bin einfach wieder weiter
geschwommen
wichtig auch nicht mehr
wie kann ich meine lage am besten mal
beschreiben ich bin gerade bei der insel
wo du bei der vorderseite
foto von hochgesprungen bist ja da
einfach geradeaus in meine richtung land
schwimmen da ist ein wohnturm und da bin
ich gerade geradeaus in richtung also
einfach mal über meine insel wo ich
fahre ja okay dann dann weiß ich war ja
ich sie auf den turm im horizont ein
alter über einen noten blog aber da war
überhaupt 0 drin aber ich habe eine
grafik einstellungen nicht fest
aber ganz ehrlich das lehrschreiben doch
ohne ob tief ein
naja ich hab es aber gerade extra auf
normal gesetzt damit dass im hintergrund
zum neblig ist nicht weil ich nicht
genug fds ab ich habe gerade 60 fps also
ich nehme mit fraps und 60fps auf aber
nicht mitnehmen jetzt einfach mal mit
dieser normal perspektive auch weil das
so cool ist weil er im hintergrund also
nebel ist ein bisschen mystisch aus
selig aber ich glaube hier war schon
jemand dann würde ich doch vorschlagen
wir gehen einfach auf gegner jagd und
wollen von denen die items war für uns
jetzt auch schon virtuell ganzen tonia
haag an dann suchen wir die töten wir
die ihr gesagt du ich habe einen bogen
mit dem kann ich nicht viel im nahkampf
machen
hast du denn viele überhaupt drei stück
als ob ich daran nicht denken würde was
unter stellst du mir drei fällen ist
eine menge du
damit kann ich dir schon mal gut von ihr
fernhalten wollte ich auch machen da geh
ich auf das hühnchen okay jetzt auch das
will ich ihm geht auch nicht jawohl ich
habe alle fehler bekommen dafür ein
bisschen scheint wo darf sein
da ist gerade jemand gelaufen wo genau
davon
da waren wir doch eben gerade da habe
ich eben namen gesehen na ja gut wir
können ja hier eigentlich mal weiter
laufen wo du auch schon halle bis
richtig finde denn ich hab dich gefunden
ich komme gleich gut
ich weiß dass hier noch eine kiste ist
warte ja und ich glaube wo ich gehe man
stückchen da oben sind zwei namen im
wald im wald in wahl kommen hier schnell
mit da oben bis in 2 ok dann lasst uns
auf die jetzt einfach drauf einstellen
oder nicht mist action einfach auf die
action action action action schlagen sie
sich nicht schlagen dann dass sie
schlagen wir schauen mal doch die
schlange
einer hat keine items von bayern von
anderen
hierunter wo bist du denn drauf
ok warte ich lauf in deine richtung
siehst du mich
hilfe hilfe hier bin ich lieber nicht
mit leisen schwer drogenabhängigen den
weg gelaufen aufgekauft nein nein ich
bin auch tot
am meisten aber jetzt auch komplette
rüstungen eisen schwer das war womöglich
doch nicht werden gar keine rüstung ist
na ja auf jeden fall ne witzfigur runde
wurde eine schlechte arbeit server kann
ich nur weiterempfehlen ich denke werde
ich in zukunft einfach hier auf
umsteigen weil das mit dem namenszug
plugin etc sehr gut funktioniert denke
jetzt nicht dass ich immer thorsten die
blinkt bin oder vita ist und vielleicht
wirst du auch irgendwann mal hier die
ersten survival points rund machen kann
ja auch sein kann wie du sagst mal wegen
eurer geil ich stehe hier vor 2000 da
kann man ja auch mal aufnahmen machen
und hier startet rein theoretisch kann
arena wo ihr eine spielart reingenommen
irgendwie vl foto zu machen wir dann
nachher einfach jetzt einfach so ich bin
doch drin
herrlich jojo angekommen ich werde dann
sehen wir uns jetzt einfach beim
nächsten mal freunde und auch van bommel
hat die gebe ich jetzt einmal die
letzten worte jetzt ganz normal deine
familie grüßen alle ok ich bedanke mich
bei meiner familie bei meinen freunden
beim europa bei meiner oma bei meinen
verwandten bei all meinen freunden die
mich immer unterstützt haben auf diesem
wege hier
ich bedanke mich bei luca ich bedanke
mich bei konny reimann
ich bedanke mich bei müller reist vielen
dank für alles ich wünsche euch noch
einen schönen tag ich hoffe mal euch hat
die folge gefallen
wenn ja was gern eine positive bewertung
dahin